[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade Washoe Ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions for free and some
say the advice is worth what you pay for
it so join us the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we're glad you're here thanks for
joining us Kristen is with us in
Pittsburgh to start off this hour hi
Kristen how are you
I'm great Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
well I'm calling cuz my husband and I
are both 55 years old we have a um a
good income primarily mine
we make over 300 000 a year and we have
for about the past um 10 years and
um successfully paid off our student
loans in a 10-year period over 125 000
only owe about thirty five thousand
dollars on our um four hundred thousand
dollar home mortgage wow and um have no
no revolving credit or debt we don't
drive cars that we have car payments on
we pay for those in cash
um we don't you know we don't have any
kind of debt in that way good for you
the problem is that we don't have a nest
egg we're not saving and so looking down
the road I want to be able to retire at
some point and I'm just trying to come
up with some options of how we should be
um taking our money and and investing it
and potentially not just paying our
children's students
payments you know to colleges out of the
cash that we have maybe using it for
something different so you have some
cash
we did we do so I did I get a a nice
bonus every year in March how much cash
do you have
well typically we have about 75 000 a
year and and typically right now how
much cash do you have oh right this
second none because we just paid two
College tuitions oh she got two in
college
we have two in college one already
graduated yes okay cool
cool good for you all right and so your
cash flowing College out of your 300K
but you have no debt except 35 000 on
your mortgage
thing into retirement
yes so I we put in 10 in my 401k and
then we also do an additional five
percent in a Roth IRA
okay so you're doing baby step four
fifteen percent of your income going
into retirement right
yes how long have you been doing that
we've only been doing that since um well
the bigger chunk of it we were doing
about eight percent up until two years
ago and now for the past two years we're
up to 15 okay if you never get a raise
for 10 years you make three hundred
thousand and you put 15
of your income aside for retirement for
a decade you will be rich
okay you're doing everything exactly
right okay now and I mean I guess we
need to Define Rich you won't be a
billionaire but you'll be a millionaire
now but let's let's play out though what
you should be doing which is more than
that
um so okay you don't have any cash but
you have an emergency fund
how much is in it well
um I would say that we are it's just in
our bank account with Ted averages
somewhere between ten and fifteen
thousand dollars okay in our bank
account I would move that to a separate
Place let's move that to like a high
yield savings account and get it out of
the checking account so that it's clear
this is money for three to six months of
emergencies maybe put a little bit more
with it yeah it sounds a little low for
three to six months okay yeah and do you
have any other non-retirement
Investments
um we have property we have two separate
properties oh and my husband is an um is
an antique car collector and so he uses
but you don't have any you don't have
any mutual funds or stocks or anything
that are not in a retirement account
no no other savings that you're leaving
out here
no
now the other
flowing do they have debt on them
but they're not cash flowing he uses
them for his hobbyist he's a hobbyist
um for his cars so he uses them to house
those potentially we could turn around
and sell our house yeah you're good
you're full yeah I mean yeah so you need
35 Grand to knock the house out as soon
as you knock the house out 35 Grand you
got to cover tuition you knock the 35
000 out on the house then you're at what
we call baby step seven around here
meaning there's nothing left to do but
build wealth and be outrageously
generous okay so you'll finish up
college and then you're gonna have 300
000 plus to invest then you would max
out every 401K every Roth IRA that you
have available to you and you're going
to even do more investing
because you're gonna have money coming
out your dead gum ears when you've got
no college students and no house payment
right
yeah we'll be excited yeah you get you
get the little goobers off the payroll
and you get the house paid off the thing
goes ding ding right
yeah so that's where you're going to be
when's the last one graduate
so our our youngest is a freshman in
college okay so three more years our
daughter's a fourth year so she'll be
done next year yeah and you just wrote
tuition checks yeah you just wrote yeah
so you're you know you're you're getting
ready to be down to one and then then
three years from now you're done and
um your house will be paid for by then
and so you're maxing out above whatever
a little bit of tuition you got and then
when tuition's all gone three years from
today you're 58 and you're making three
350 or whatever it is at that point
and you start chunking away everything
you can in any kind of retirement
program to keep the stupid government's
hands off of your money okay yeah and
then above that you start investing
further in mutual funds and in other
things that you if you buy real estate
you pay cash for it and the next Real
Estate you buy needs to be income
producing not hobbyist
yeah no more toys until we get the house
paid off and we got we got the
retirement underway
okay okay I got a 1960 Corvette I love
toys I'm not against toys I'm not
anti-toys I'm anti-toys when you're
house isn't paid for
okay so paying off the houses
easy yeah now in my in my that's why I
was searching for cash I wanted you to
pay it off today I had a feeling you had
a little bit of something under the
couch cushion somewhere and I couldn't
find it okay oh how much is that
um probably about 80 000. oh good okay
pay a thousand Mark okay good
and then start chunking and then crank
up everything see if you'll run the math
out and good growth stock mutual funds
averaging 11 which is what the stock
market's average since it started in uh
in your 401ks in your Roth IRAs with
matches where you can you run the
numbers out on that from 55 56 years old
to 66 you're going to see an incredible
number at the end of that
okay you're fine that makes me feel
better you're fine what you do need is
you need to be very precise in what your
next steps are because otherwise you'll
buy another antique car
you are right yeah I mean we all we all
have the antique car somewhere and so
it's a metaphor for buying crap out of
order you know before we've got the
other stuff done you shouldn't be
wringing your hands about retirement and
have a barn full of cars
that's kind of that that's fast that's
right that's just wrong so there you go
yeah this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 50 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
thanks for joining us America we're so
glad you are here open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
well one week
one week we'll be there that's right be
doing uh the student loan live stream
how we got student loan debt how we got
here how we get out that's right and you
and me and Rachel Jade being the 280
thousand dollar example of having paid
off student loans for that live stream
uh we'll be doing that for free for you
guys it's September the 12th at 7 pm
central time you do have to tune in live
that's it that's your shot and it is
free did we mention it's free
and it's probably worth more than that
100 it's probably worth the balance on
your money back if you don't like it you
can't beat that
could cut our pay in half so there you
go anyway we are yeah it's a
it's going to be a blast we're gonna
there's so much solid information out
there to give you hope and a time when
it seems overwhelming and you're
standing at the bottom of Mount Everest
looking up and you do not see Joe
Biden's face so you know that you have
to climb the mountain you know it's got
to be done you know the government is
not going to rescue you everyone has
figured that out well I see not
everybody most everyone should have
figured that out by now we'll make sure
they figure if you're slow to the party
we'll get you there but we're also going
to show you not leave you a whole plus
but show you what to do and what people
who have successfully done away with
their student loans make you believe
again in yourself
and in your ability to do this and give
you some tools to knock it out as fast
as possible by the way no magic answers
if I'm doing a live stream on barbecue
it's not going to involve microwaves
microwave barbecue 100 of the time sucks
and money is like barbecue it has to
cook if you think that you're going to
get out you got in a hundred thousand
dollars worth of student loan debt it
was easy to get in it's not going to be
easy to get out but we can get you out
that's right you just gotta be willing
to cook for a while that's it
so ramseysolutions.com student loans one
week from today September the 12th
Tuesday night at 7 p.m Central Time
completely free you need to sign up
though ahead of time for the live stream
and we'll send you the link and you'll
be able to turn it on pop it on your
television sit there and watch it pop it
on your computer screen even on your
little phone and you can watch it and
we'll do it just for you because hey we
we're you know we poke fun all the time
but we also know it's scary
and it's um overwhelming it is it's
overwhelming I hear from people all the
time on social media on Instagram and
Facebook and they don't know what to do
and I tell them I'm like look we're
doing this live stream it's practical
answers you'll be able to walk away from
it use the tools and do something that
day to better your situation so but if
you come looking for a magic wand
spoiler alert we don't have any it
doesn't exist but we will tell you what
millions of people who have been
successful in getting rid of their
student loans have done and we'll show
you exactly how to do it oh and tell
your friend who's um still living
on denial
denial River denial yeah all right
Michael is in uh Atlanta Georgia hey
Michael welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey guys thanks so much for having me uh
quick quick little synopsis of our
situation so my wife and I uh I'm 29 and
she's 25. I run a small video company so
it's just myself and then we've got two
uh like 1099 contractors that work for
us um we do about 300 and Top Line about
175 take home uh but we started
listening to the YouTube clips about six
months ago
um and then I should have started sooner
I should have listened to my wife sooner
and she was like hey we need to go full
board like no debt on anything we need
to just do the full day plan I'm like
you're right let's do it so we've got no
debt on anything except a rental
property that was our first house that
we kept uh we got no debt in our
business all the cars are paid for no
credit cards anything like that way to
go my question thank you so much um so
the uh my I guess my question is so we
we bought our townhouse in 2020 right
before the World Went Crazy
um for 217 it's probably worth 340 now
um and then we moved when we found out
she was pregnant and wanted some more
space and less stairs with the dog and
all that stuff is we have our current
residents that we owe about 3 30 on it's
worth about 450. but my question is do
we should we just go full Board sell the
townhouse we've probably got 140 000 in
equity in it and I've got about 150 in
mutual funds that I could pull out
that's not retirement uh should we just
go and you can pay off your house
that's what I'm saying but you know I
but I also say you know that that
townhouse our rental property you know
produces its rents for 17.50 we could
probably get a little more for it we're
in North Atlanta in a great area so you
know do we should we pay the townhouse
off or should we just go full board and
get the house knocked out before I'm
even 30.
okay
well one way I make some of these
decisions and if you've been binging
YouTube you've probably heard this
before is I reverse engineer it
sure let's pretend you did not have
money in a mutual fund and you did not
have a rental property and you were
sitting in a paid for 450 000 house
and you woke up this morning and said
I'm gonna go borrow 330 000 on my home
in order to buy a rental property and
put 150 000 in mutual funds
would you do that
I don't know that I would
that what that does is is it makes you
also think with your heart where you
measure risk
because when when you say that you go
women I got paid for home and for just a
moment there you were sitting in the you
know out on the patio or the cool cup
with a great cup of coffee and on that
paid for house and for just a moment it
was paid for and then I took it away
from you your stomach jumped up into
your throat a little bit even though
it's not really paid for it was just a
discussion but it still causes a
physical reaction doesn't it
yes absolutely yeah that's real once we
had our daughter that's real I I was
much more risk-averse before our
daughter came here I was like oh no
we'll go for it we'll do all these
different things I wanna I'll do ten
rentals like we're just gonna get after
it yeah and now I'm like I don't know
how it feels outside yeah now now you're
the antithesis of tick tock right so
um you know you grew your brain in it's
good having kids does that having kids
will do that for you I I I would I'm
saying all of that to say I personally
would sell in and pay it off and be debt
free because I am I'm the end of the
story okay you're you're 31 Oh no you're
not even 30. you're doing this before
you're 30 right
yes sir I'm 29. yeah I'm 63. so I did it
when I was your age
and now I've got a whole bunch of real
estate and it's all paid for I paid cash
for it as I bought it and it really does
cash flow when you don't have payments
on dude yeah like I found it with a gun
yeah yeah I'm just saying so yeah I mean
so the end of the story is it's not that
you will be without real estate as an
investment the end of the story is is
you've learned that real estate's a
great investment you've also learned
debt free is cool and the shortest path
to wealth and so I predict that when
you're 40 you'll own several pieces of
real estate that you paid cash for that
make you a lot of money
love it yeah there it is I love that I
love that reverse engineer because it
helps you see what you truly value
in a moment yeah that's a that's a good
way of saying it you know and you can do
that folks with anything I mean if
you've got a boat sitting in the
driveway you can go uh if I had that if
I had that fourteen thousand dollars in
or forty thousand dollars or whatever
that boat is right and a pile in the
middle of the table would I go buy a
boat and you go yeah I use a stinking
thing every weekend yes I'd go buy that
boat and you keep the boat right that's
right you keep the boat I got two boats
and two jet skis and I was down there
this weekend at the lake house and um
you know I I'm not selling those no not
happening uh they're not for sale yeah
and you know I got two mastercrafts the
best ski boat in the world and I got the
opportunity to buy one finally when I
got some stinking money but yeah um you
know it was that so so no I'm not
selling the boat but you you can reverse
engineer and decide to keep it yeah
that's right that's a good mental
exercise to go through though yeah with
almost anything so yeah very good
Michael I would do that but only on the
caveat that you play all the way through
and become rich and pay cash for your
real estate
so I want you to join the baby steps
millionaires league and you're not far
away and you're not even 30.
and then you know then you start saving
up and paying cash for Stuff
the weird thing is it's a reverse debt
snowball in
like when you buy your first rental
property with nobody with no debt you
make a lot of money on every month
there's no ex you got expenses
and so you got money in the account
every stinking month stocking and then
you use that money pretty quick buy
another one now you got two of them
stacking that's gonna take a three of
them
and I just buy real estate from my real
estate yeah that's I don't even touch my
regular income to buy real estate now
it's just an income snowball
ooh I like that I like that too this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey solutions by the way you
ought to come by and visit us we've
usually got 50 to 200 folks sitting and
watching us do the show we do it from
one to four central time every weekday
afternoon and uh we'd love to have you
come out and hang out with us the lobby
is of course free there's all kinds of
Ramsay things to do around here
including free coffee and free homemade
chocolate chip cookies and you get to
watch from the debt free stage some debt
free screams Isaiah is here to do just
that hey Isaiah how are you hey how's it
going better than I deserve where do you
live sir I live in Tampa Florida awesome
very cool welcome to Nashville and how
much debt have you paid officer 176
thousand dollars yeah yeah how long did
this take it took me six years good for
you and your range of income during that
time I began at 41 000 and I ended up at
around 95 000. wow good for you wow what
are you do for a living I'm an I.T guy
and for my side gig I'm on the radio I
knew it
that's so fun sorry that was an outburst
oh it's all good
you do so what are you doing radio uh
producing shows from fishing shows
Sports shows any type of thing they want
me I'm here let's go for fun and get to
do some Voice work in the middle of it I
do yes very good good for you very fun
what kind of debt was the 176. it was
just a mortgage you paid off your house
yep that was it look at it
game oh man way to go it wasn't anything
related to you know mortgages credit
card debt now I already had that done
and gone out of the door yeah just a
mortgage just a mortgage six years ago
you get on this journey making forty one
thousand and you end up paying off your
home and everything making 95 in the end
of the story how old are you I am 34.
what's the house what's the house worth
uh now it's worth almost 450
000.
and how much is in your retirement
accounts uh I wish it was a little bit
more it's around 150 000. good for you
net worth and you're only 30. man that's
just great I gotta keep going yeah
you're on your way you'll be baby step
millionaire in no time excellent
excellent okay so what happened six
years ago that put you on this Ramsay
Journey so what happened was that I was
getting my mortgages and I was just
paying the minimum and I was looking at
the interest and it was just a couple of
pennies every time that was going less
and I'm like just a couple of pennies
that's it so I was like you know what
let me do something let me research
something and I was recently single too
at the time and I was going on Facebook
and I was like dating group I was
scrolling around and I found something
for Dave Ramsey dating group I was like
who stayed Ramsey dating group so I I
began to do some research and I was like
oh a finance crew let me actually jump
in a little bit let me talk to these
cool cats they were talking about baby
steps and I was like what is baby steps
so I began to do more research I was
like oh okay so right now I'm on bs6 how
can I do do bs7 so I was thinking of
going to gazelle mode which I which yep
and then I was like okay let's go
gazelle let's do what we need to do to
get that to be zero there you go so very
cool yeah it was fun it was exciting it
really was so who was on your side
during all this you you decide that
you're going like animal mode going
gazelle mode on this mortgage were there
people around you who are like dude
you're 34 like you can just you've got
time or was there somebody who was like
come on dude you you need to have
ambition you need to have the passion
it's just because of what I saw with my
with my family I saw my mom she was one
of those 1980s you know oh credit card
let me slap it and forget it type of
thing and then it took around 25 years
to pay that off so I was like you know
what I don't want to be like that let me
do something different and you just have
to be self-motivated because being debt
free is great yeah way to go
so the the odd pop-up site that we have
by the way disclaimer we have nothing to
do with any dating sites nothing nothing
yeah full disclaimer here and yes it's
been proposed as many times as the beans
and rice cookbook so don't send me the
proposal okay we're not doing it why not
oh man I'm just glad you I'm glad you
wandered in the back door man it's just
amazing man it's very cool the dating
group had some cool cats in it and you
know I I had a lot of fun and we all
helped each other out yeah to resolving
to become everyone being debt-free I
love it really nice very good wow good
for you man well done how's it feel to
not have a house payment at 34 years old
I I don't I don't know what to do with
my money except let's reinvest it let's
let's put it up in my 401k let's Max it
out that's awesome good for you that's
really cool are you are you doing
anything to celebrate are you going
anywhere what's the big trip what's
actually I had a big party a few weeks
ago actually over at my house I invited
my friends it was like a double party
because not only did I become debt free
but I also got uh I finished off in my
second bachelor's degree with my job
they do free education always max out
those benefits so that's what I did and
got myself a second bachelor's and I'm
going for my Master's and I'm looking
for my doctorates let's go wow why not
game on yeah yeah I don't have to pay
let's go this is very there's nothing
wrong with this no I'm not done sir
thank you done well done okay so when
the guys at the party they said okay
you're 34 years old you have paid for
450 000 house this is weird
how did you do that what do you tell
them the key is to getting out of debt
the key is be self-motivated is to have
passion within yourself because if you
don't have that passion you're not going
to do it and don't listen to most of
that media saying that that's cool
that's not cool you know you got to pay
off the debt you got to get yourself
debt free and it's like change it's like
it's like being uncuffed from being in
prison or something you know you're free
you can do whatever you want and it's
and it's fun and it's a cool Journey
from going from different baby steps and
whatnot and I try to encourage my
friends to do the same thing and live
that Ramsay lifestyle wow and someone
will do it some of them want that'll be
perfect well very good man
congratulations proud of you thank you
we're excited for you well done and
appreciate you taking the trip here to
Nashville to do your debt free scream
we've got the live and give box for you
for you to have the baby steps
millionaires book which is definitely
the journey that you're on you won't be
there forever it won't be long for until
you're there and Total Money Makeover
book to give to somebody and get them
started and even Financial Peace
University members ship all of that just
to say thanks for coming up here and you
can live some of it you can give some of
it so it's perfect sounds very cool very
cool who did you bring along to cheer
you on here my friend Jocelyn she too is
on the Dave Ramsey Journey baby steps
right now so she wants to see what the
good life is like all right here we go
all right find out what it's like to be
truly weird well done Isaiah you've
joined the club my man I'm proud of you
all right Isaiah from Tampa Florida 176
thousand dollars paid off in six years
making 41 to 95 000. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one on
debt free yeah
that is how it's done yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes man his
enthusiasm was contagious infectious you
know the first time I took a call or
somebody on the debt free stage that I
had paid off their home I was aghast
and then the first time
I had somebody that was like 40 years
old
pay off their home I was aghast and now
it seems like every week we've got a
30-something in here with their homes
paid off I know and are almost
millionaires already uh it's like
happening earlier and earlier and
earlier the younger generation is
catching on faster than the Boomers did
that's true yes they are I'm
yes aghast is the word yeah it just it I
mean it's wow wonderful not a payment in
the world and he's not even 35 years old
yeah and light is light is a feather not
touching the ground when he walks I mean
that's this is how it works you know
it's it because you don't have to carry
all those chains around and uh you know
it changes how you work it changes where
you work it changes the quality of your
relationships your ability to set
boundaries in toxic areas of your life
when you have no money problems
is pretty powerful yeah and uh he he
didn't have that in his story that we
know of anyway but just to let you know
if you don't have any payments and the
ball starts yelling you can just start
walking off yeah I'm leaving where are
you going I don't have any payments
laughs I'm not putting up with this crap
next I mean it changes everything boys
and girls changes how you walk
and because you're not you don't walk
like a slave anymore you walk like a
free person it changes
it's worth it it's hard but it changes
everything this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than thirty
four thousand customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America
Aston is with us in Ashton is with us
Aston I'm sorry is with us in Akron Ohio
hi Ashton how are you
hello I'm good how are you thank you so
much for having me sure how can we help
so I since I have met you through the
interwebs I have referred to you as my
financial father prior to discovering
all the Ramsey products I didn't know
anything about how to handle money that
was never discussed growing up and
neither did my husband
um but with all the time we had on our
hands staying home at the beginning of
the covid crisis
um we found you again and we signed up
for Financial Peace University we
dedicated every Sunday to go join the
class online we went through it uh that
was February 2020 since then we've paid
off 160 000. why did it go yes so my
next call will be a debt free debt free
scream and hopefully we can do it in
person but
um that's uh hopefully soon but we have
our house left of course and about 45
000 in debt left to pay off aside from
the mortgage and really I'm looking for
advice or some kind of push on how to
gain some traction we kind of feel like
we're stuck I don't know if it's been a
change in
just all the changes with the world
today and the prices of things we also
have my mom living with us since March
so that's changed some things
financially
um and covering her expenses
um
but I feel like this last 45
000 is it just feels like forever it's
not like it's not going anywhere is it
because your margin has dramatically
decreased or is it just you're getting
tired of chucking the money towards the
debts every month
I don't think we're getting tired I I
know that we're still pretty excited
because I mean we we do still have our
meetings my husband and I we do them
every other week uh where we're sitting
down and looking at our budget and our
spreadsheet of all things and
um we see how it's working it's just for
some reason this 45 and then how our
budget has added to
change so you don't have as much money
going towards it
oh no we do have money going towards it
you have as much as you used to
oh yeah yeah we do okay all right let's
stop a second what's your household in
okay
um bring home is 1436. okay and how much
are you how quick do you think you're
gonna have the 45 done
what's your project I'm hoping to have
it no no you got numbers it's not hope
what do the numbers what 16 months 16
months
one six
for forty five thousand making 145 000.
so you can't live on a hundred
what's that you can't live on 100 for
the next year
uh we can we're we're also paying
um well like we have my mom living with
us too so Oliver how old is your mom
well you know just 66.
okay you started you're muffled like you
cover your phone or something
um
66. okay yeah and why why is she living
with you
uh she had to move out from her home due
to some domestic violence
okay so there's a divorce in process
uh no no divorce involved no she wasn't
married at the time now
so she didn't own the home
no so it wasn't her home
no she was renting is she able to work
at all
she does work some yes does she take
Social Security
no because she contributed to your
household at all
she does when she can she has a lot of
medical bills that were owned from from
that uh attack I guess if you want to
call it
um so she's covering those bills at the
time she didn't have insurance
because she got you know hit with all
the bills so trying to help her where we
can
um
so like the grocery bills all that has
adjusted
um how many kids do you have we have
three kids
okay so mom's in the house
correct me if I'm wrong mom's in the
house so now you're buying a little bit
of extra food there's maybe a little
increase in water
electricity that sort of thing
yes
that's not that's not changing yeah that
doesn't feel like the reason that this
is slowed down my question to you I
asked it a couple of times and I felt
like you were kind of going back and
forth I think that you're just
um one of two things is happening either
you're not putting as much money to the
debt and therefore it's not moving
which it sounded like you said initially
but then you said no we're putting just
as much on it so no you better be true
you paid off 160 000 right
yes yes in what period of time three
years uh from February 2020 to
well August
so almost three years yeah almost yeah I
think based on what you're telling us I
think it's 55 000 a year
yes
okay that's not 45 000 over 16 months
so your energy has slowed down you're
not putting as much towards the debt as
you were yeah that's what we were saying
you should be done with this in like 12
8 to 12 months somewhere in there if you
turn it back up I think um I don't know
I'll give you a guess you the way you
mentioned Mom and then you tell us what
has happened with your mom the trauma
she's been through and how um
the emotions around some dirt bag
hitting your mother to the point that
she needs medical attention are very
strong
if you're a redneck it means you want to
kill somebody okay like him okay not
saying you should I just said it makes
you want to because that's actually what
he deserves okay so uh but the uh so the
emotions around that so not only did mom
come in and is eating a little bit of
food what Mom did come in and do was use
up a whole lot of your emotional
bandwidth right now yeah
which is okay because you're supposed to
take care of her because she got the
crud beat out of her that's horrible
right I mean I'm so glad you're there
for her but I think you're you know you
guys had a singular purpose in life
coming out of the fauci quarantine
your singular purpose in life was get
out of debt
wasn't it
yeah and now you've got like two or
three purposes
and so it's it's diluting some of your
emotional focus and energy uh at least
one of the purposes is valid but just
recognizing that it's there helps you
deal with it and that is I'm probably
slowing down just because I'm you know
mom's situation is taking up some part
of my emotional bandwidth
I think she's hitting you all harder
there than she is in the pocketbook
I would probably agree with you yeah and
again I I want to validate that I think
that's probably the right thing to do
she needs you to be there
she needs to remember she's not a victim
that or she is a victim but she's not a
worthy of what happened to her because
that's what goes the shame that goes
with domestic violence so helping her
turn the corner on this and getting her
to where she can contribute to your
household financially would be good for
her dignity in this as well so that'd be
okay if she started either getting a job
or collecting Social Security I don't
care which and dumping that in the
middle of Euros table to help cover the
the you know food and housing right now
that's good and and then we also need to
work out a long-term plan
which is not her living here for 25
years
um until she's 94. we're not doing that
so we gotta we need a better plan than
that but short term you've been a safety
net and you should
yeah I think they're I think you're
right Dave I think you hit on something
with the emotional part because I think
that's what people tend to do when
something emotional happens every it's
like you go out to dinner more you're
tired you don't cook it as much at home
you she doesn't probably doesn't want to
say no to much of what her mom is
requesting like there's all of these
things that make you feel like how can I
help how can I just decompress from this
moment and unfortunately sometimes that
includes spending dollars and I think
that's what's happened here you relax
and as soon as you relax money flows to
stupid sure does and I'm not saying
you're doing a bunch of stupid at all I
I don't think you are but there's
singular focus is what got you 160 done
in two and a half years and singular
more singular Focus to the extent you
can and still take care of your mom is
what will get you moving again kiddo
you're doing better than it feels like
you're doing I think I think so too and
I think you're an amazing daughter well
done this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jay if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade wash all Ramsay
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money Mike is
with us in Wilmington North Carolina hey
Mike welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
um I have
um my wife and I have been talking we're
considering selling our home
um of course the prices on on houses
just skyrocketed and uh so we could put
a lot of money in our pocket so right
now we owe approximately
243 000 uh that's a mortgage and a HELOC
um and our total date is two little over
in uh credit card
um we got five thousand a little over
five thousand five thousand one hundred
left on a car
and a personal loan from a family member
from a few years back of like 26.5
uh so we're paying on all of that every
month so total debt a little over 299
243 of it is the house
um we talked about possibly selling the
house
because after sailing the house
um paying the fees and closing and
mortgage payoff HELOC and everything
uh and then paying off all of our debt
uh to being completely debt free we
would have approximately two hundred and
seven thousand dollars in cash
uh we could set aside you know thirty
thousand dollars for emergency fund for
six months
and still have a a pretty good lump sum
that we could put away somewhere for a
year until we decide what we want to do
and and we're in another house for a
year or two how much do you make what's
your income
uh my income and uh
annually I'll say monthly is 11 500 but
that's not every month my I work for a
utility company and so spring and fall I
make a little more uh other times it's
straight 40 hours a week yeah it works
it averages out excuse me does your wife
work outside the home
she does not okay so your household
income's around 130 right
130 135. you've got about fifty thousand
dollars of non-mortgage debt do you not
like your house
uh I do like the house uh it's in a nice
location and convenient to everything
does your wife like that we got the
house at a good deal yeah she likes it
we we fixed it up the way we wanted it
because it needed a total Remodel and
I have I have a theory
I have a theory can I tell you my theory
yes ma'am I think that you're kind of um
trying to get around
what it might take to pay off fifty
seven thousand dollars of debt
and I think in your mind the easiest
route is because it ain't real estate
markets up we can sell our house we can
get this money we can knock all these
things out quickly
but I'm not sure
that that's going to be the solution to
your problem
we can knock out the HELOC we can lock
out knock out this personal loan knock
out this car save up our money it's kind
of like a quick fix but I'm looking at
your income and I'm like wow if you love
the house you fixed it up the way that
you want why not just walk through the
process of budgeting
cutting down your lifestyle to nothing
sacrificing and just paying off this
fifty seven thousand dollars of debt
with intensity then you'll walk through
the process of saving up three to six
months of expenses make 135 put 30 a
year on it for two years you're done
you're done
and you get to keep the house that
you've made exactly the way you want it
and here's the side benefit of that
you will have fixed the guy
and the gal
that caused this mess in the first place
because they will have learned to quit
using the stupid but credit cards are
borrowing to buy a car and for God's
sakes won't be borrowing from family
ever again
because I mean if you'd learn to live on
less than you make dramatically to pay
off debt it changes the person in your
mirror
which which is your long-term
sustainable fix
the house thing doesn't change the
person in your mirror
and you if you don't change your habits
even after selling the house you'll be
back in debt in five years
that make sense to you
yeah it does there were there was some
little background behind that my wife
and I actually divorced
a little over a year ago we were
separated three and a half years ago we
divorced a little over a year ago
we both came to a realization and and
and that we're better together I went to
a Christmas play last year and it said
there's nothing too broken or too
foregone that God can't fix amen and and
we God healed your marriage and you're
back together got back together
very cool yes that is very cool that is
awesome yes how does that and that
that's a beautiful Story how does that
uh
keep you it would seem to me like that
and equips you
to do hard things together
it does absolutely yeah instead of and
yeah so let me ask you this in that
context maybe we keep trying to read
your mind that's not fair but
um in that context are you just trying
to do something nice for her get rid of
this stress
without her having to feel it the stress
has more the stress is more of me
because I am the one that works outside
the home and I see yeah but you you want
to clean this mess up without causing
this lady that God gave back to you
any inconvenience
either that or this debt represents I
want to be able to have this money set
aside to basically so we can start
leaving them I'll be 58 years old and
and um yeah I want you to take two years
in order 60-year debt free except your
house that's what I would tell you yeah
I mean and we already but when we
divorce we never split up anything so
everything is stealing both of our names
with three rental properties in it
that's paying income into the IRA hey
worth over uh like 1.2 million
even even more reason
to pay this off in less than two years
even more reason
I'll go ahead and drop a three rental
property uh bomb on me at the end of the
call and I don't know what to do with
that okay so except it's in an IRA so
you can't touch it so we'll just keep
moving but uh
yeah if I was in your shoes I would grab
her by the hand and say honey we just
finished one hard thing let's do one
more hard thing and let's roll up our
sleeves and live on nothing for the next
18 to 24 months and be a hundred percent
debt free except our house get rid of
the family loan praise God thank you
Jesus whoa has anybody ever said family
loan and it made you feel all warm and
fuzzy not gives you the heebie-jeebies
yeah
wow it's not good just lost two more
hairs oh my gosh gotta go through the
process Steve that's what I would do man
and hang on we'll sign you guys up for
Financial Peace University we'll be uh
part of the next chapter of your
marriage growing and healing and show
you guys how to work this stuff together
uh it will work and I I personally if
unless you hate the house I would
definitely not sell it I would fix the
guy in my mirror and get this
overspending down and cause it to be
under spending and use it it to get out
of debt
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
well a week from Friday and Saturday
will be in Chicago doing a smart
conference if you want to be smarter
we'd love to have you we'll actually be
up north of Chicago but Willow Creek
Church that's the venue that we're using
they're letting us come there and do our
smart conference on Friday night and all
day Saturday we'd love to have you if
you're in the Chicagoland area Jade will
be there speaking George Campbell Rachel
Cruz Dr John deloney Ken Coleman we're
going to be talking about every area of
your life it is a wonderfully
entertaining Friday night and all day
Saturday you will leave inspired and
informed and smarter that's right what
are you gonna be talking on this year
I'm going to be talking about reclaiming
your freedom from debt there you go okay
which is what you did that's right
exactly smart conference Chicago go to
ramseysolutions.com events you can still
get a ticket I think so check it out I
think you can still get in we'd love to
have of you make a plan Jill is with us
in Dallas Texas hi Jill welcome to the
Ramsay show
oh hi guys
hi guys sorry 18 year old granddaughter
who's in her last year of high school
and wants to go to college and I just
found out that her father is refusing to
pay any college fees for her and I'm
devastated so I want to set up an
account possibly in a mutual fund for
her I don't have a lot of time I have
about a year to graduate next spring and
then go to college a year so and I was
wondering what kind of mutual fund I
could put it into to gain the most
not enough to fix this
how much would I have to
understand seventeen-year-old
granddaughter
yes but I raised her
you raised her
yes from the time her parents weren't
married and my husband and I did a lot
of babysitting and practically raised
her and helped him out tremendously and
if I don't regret helping her out I love
her
I wasn't questioning that I was just
trying to get understand what's going on
here and so uh you've you've been in the
family for 20 years
oh more than that yeah but since she was
born right uh-huh okay
um so
the stepson doesn't want to help or just
can't help her dad
he's he's got a lot of problems he's a
narcissist my husband passed away three
years ago that was his father and left
him some money and he's blown off he's
blown through it you have no money left
and he's had another child and he's not
married so
trying to get help from him is not going
to probably work okay
so this is not a complete family unit
that you're interfering in more like a
splintered family unit and you've been
the one holding it together you and your
husband before we passed
right uh-huh exactly my um
the the mother of my daughter of my
granddaughter I'm in touch with her she
and I are fine how much can you devote
to her College
well I have quite a bit of money put
away from my old age and I'm hesitant
what's quite a bit
I have about a million one okay that's
good well done yeah so how much do you
want to devote to her College
well that's what I kind of needed to
help you help me with I um let's pretend
that we didn't try to invest our way out
of this in one year which is called
called desperation and sets you up for a
get rich quick or get get scammed or
something we're not going to do that
let's just try to get a plan together
and pay for this kid's College all right
okay so the average in-state tuition
what state does the Child live in
she lives in California she is talking
about going out of state but I'm not
sure where yet she doesn't know yet
average grade yeah
can she move to you can she move in with
you
well I'm going to be there in a couple
of weeks and talk to her yes and I was
going to ask her if she wanted to
entertain that yeah I want her to have
Texas
uh residents and you need to find out
what that means for the University of
Texas at Dallas
okay because not it's not a bad school
at all and Texas yeah and um not Austin
I'm talking Dallas
I can live with you and go there and get
a great education
yeah that was in the back of my mind and
like I said I'm going to talk to her and
her mama in a couple of weeks okay so
here's the here's the thing
school choice is 90 percent of the
problem with student loan debt
yes people pay stupid prices to go to
stupid schools and study stupid things
and they get stupid
okay so let's don't be stupid about
education this is a kid from a
splintered situation her step
grandmother for God's sakes her fairy
godmother is stepping in to fix this
guess what you're going to use that
muscle to force her to make good choices
for her own good good choices is
reasonable College tuition out of state
tuition by definition is not reasonable
in this situation
okay you are paying for nothing except
you cross the state line it is
absolutely zero value
zero one of my kids applied we live in
Tennessee when they were in college age
applied for and was accepted to the
University of Mississippi which is a
wonderful little SEC school no problem
with it at all only it's three times the
price of the University of Tennessee
because it's across a state line
right so instead of today's world
instead of uh 25
000 you pay 8 000 to go in state to
basically the same school
just a different color on the football
jersey okay well and some play better
football than others but anyway but
aside from that right so you know the
number of people that have applied at
Ramsey we have 1100 folks working here
that we did not hire because they went
to the University of Texas at Dallas
versus the University of uh Timbuktu
across the state line is precisely zero
as a matter of fact we count it towards
your wisdom and count it towards a badge
of honor to get hired if you used some
dadgum sense while getting your degree
does that make sense right so this is
what you put your little arm around her
Little Neck and explain life to her
Granny's going to pay for this but
you're going to do it Granny's way
[Music]
and then you can get through this for
she can go to Community College for two
years if she wants to probably pay
nothing get her get her requirements out
of the way or core stuff out of the way
and you can get through this for under
50 Grand
well that would be great no it's not
great it's factual
yeah but for me it would be okay yeah
yeah you can handle 50 grand out of 1.1
and you would right you do that in Army
but am I going to spend 150k for her to
get basically the same education through
a series of stupid butt choices at other
places no no she does not need a lazy
river
some of these stupid but schools have a
lazy river you can ride through in an
inner tube yeah this is how stupid but
this stuff has gotten
she just is uneducated regarding this
and I'm going to have to educate her
well these are the let me tell you in
our stuff that we've studied and Jade
we've talked about this a lot
um Anthony O'Neill that was a Ramsey
personality African-American guy for a
long time we kept he kept saying it was
African-Americans that were running up
uh student loan debt uh uniquely in
ridiculous degrees and I said no that's
not it I don't buy that and so we got to
dig into it and he and I were digging
into the research and what we found was
just exactly what you described it has
nothing to do with skin color it has to
do with first generation to go to
college yeah whether you're you know
whether you're a hillbilly like me or
African-American first generation to go
to college doesn't have college educated
parents to guide them through the
stupidity of higher education
that's true and so they end up spending
250 000 getting a degree a master's
degree in sociology so they can work at
the state making 38 000 as a caseworker
which is dumber than crap
I've listened to you guys a long time
talking about this and it really upset
me when I first heard that she was going
to take out student debts no she's not
she's got a grandmother's not going to
let her yeah I'll take care of you but
you're going to do it my way no debt
we're going to choose a school that is
reputable and a good solid education
okay great advice great advice thank you
so much thank you you can do this you're
a good lady I will yeah I will take
control for her sake take control of it
don't don't be acquiescing to 17 year
olds wishes
that you're not you know she don't even
though I'm your Fairy Godmother you get
no wishes
this oh that's a line
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you three months free to
get started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and
remember Halo is giving you 90 days free
imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hollow.com
Ramsay today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Tim and
Karen are with us hey guys how are you
good good we're great welcome where do
you live
or we live in Detroit Michigan ah cool
welcome to Nashville good to have you
guys and all the way here to do a debt
free scream how much have you paid off
80 000. all right how long did that take
about five years good for you and your
range of income during that time I think
we were at 36 000 and then now we're at
88 000. good for you well done what do
you all do for a living
um I'm an apprentice for for uh
uh foreign for an electrical company and
um I'm I'm in finance okay great great
very cool what kind of debt was the 80
000 uh school debt
um a lot of it and then uh credit cards
and car payments very good good for you
guys way to go man I'm proud of y'all
very well
all right so you paid off
paid off well we don't have a house yet
because you're renting you're 100 debt
free right now yes way to go very good
five years starting out making 36 000
bucks how long y'all been married 25
years uh this year so that that's kind
of why we came to Nashville to see you
but also celebrate 25 years of marriage
amen amen so at 20-year Mark you're in
debt 80 grand mm-hmm this sucks yeah we
did stupid and you're going uh I don't
like this so whose idea was it to make
this change and how did you guys do this
and how did you connect to Ramsey uh
well I'll let my wife explain that well
uh
we first heard about Dave Ramsey
um from your parents about 20
three years ago from my family but we
thought you were a pyramid scheme ah
okay
we no we only sell snake oil
and then
um fast forward to about seven I believe
seven years ago I was talking to a
friend and um uh shout out to Helen and
Charlie we were talking and she was
talking about she read your book and
um she was talking about how they were
going to get out of debt and they were
going to become Millionaires and I was
like what you joined the pyramid world
are you talking about I real I thought
it was just I thought it was a scam yeah
and so uh she said those of us in
finance we have a high degree of
spiritual cynicism which is a good thing
I agree with you I would have thought we
were a scam too yeah so
um so she said you got to read the book
and so we actually watched the DVDs read
the book and we drank the Kool-Aid and
um and we've been crazy ever since all
right I love that you watch DVDs that's
great yeah those were five years ago
yeah good on VHS I guess yeah
Jade
your income it went from 36
000 to 88 000 what happened there so I
was a stay-at-home mom for 17 years we
have four adult children now but of
course back then
um
uh seven years ago or so they were they
were smaller
um younger and um uh one of our sons is
Special Needs
um he's high functioning and he's doing
great now but at the time he couldn't be
home he couldn't be alone and so we
decided that I wanted to go back to work
um but we had a unique situation because
he can't be home alone he can go to
school but somebody has to be home when
he's home and with school schedules and
working eight to five we just we were
looking for an option
um and so I went back to school and got
my degree I went back to school or went
back to work full-time by then he had
matured enough that he could be home
alone
um so he's he's doing great that's
awesome so I went back to work and um
and did lots of side gigs love it bigger
shovel you guys over doubled your income
between the two of you we sold
everything yeah I told the kids if they
Stood Still long enough I would sell
them there you go I like it I like it
Wow way to go you guys side gigging is a
side gang is a real it
people don't realize you talk about it
but there are so many side gigs out
there oh yeah
um what was the best one that paid the
best for you
you in these yard sale probably well we
did
oh I used to um when I was in school I
was I was wanting to be out of debt so
bad but I felt so limited because I I
didn't feel like I had a marketable
degree we we both graduated from college
25 years ago but with the degrees that
were not marketable and so that's why we
had most of this debt and um
and so I felt so
um I didn't feel like I could offer much
because I I'm hopeless yeah I felt
hopeless because I I couldn't we
couldn't leave our son and so
um so I would be taking the kids to
school and I would it would be trash day
and I would see people's trash on the
side of the road and I said nice trash
um I can pick that up and we started
doing that and we had multiple yard
sales we would fill the garage up and we
would pull it all out and we wow we sold
other people's trash one man's trash
another man's treasure so that was
really that was really not major that's
your best side gig no that probably
wasn't the best probably my best side
gig is um I do caregiving on the side I
love that's that I love taking care of
the elderly um I don't go into the
nursing homes I just take care of them
in their home yeah so that's probably
the best and then the other one is
probably
um I also iron for people on the side I
love it interesting so you're you
literally go pick up their house your
their clothes from their house take them
to your house iron them and re-deliver
them yes wow
that's that's a service I might that's
uh it's really very very happy yeah yeah
a lot of people it's like cooking they
don't know how to do it anymore you know
because we have these things called
restaurants that run into the kitchen
yeah well it just goes to shows where we
open a box where there's a will there's
a way ah way I mean picking up trash
ironing people's clothes
okay 80 000 in five years what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is congratulations thank you
um I think that it's when you live
according to God's design and you don't
try to make life work apart from God I
mean because when you do you you just
get frustrated and God hey and God has a
design for everything and he has done
are you so he has a design for money you
know and if we just do it his way you
know He blesses amen you have to we've
we've always made tithing a priority
um you have to tithe you have to you
have to put God first because when you
do God blesses you you talk about when
you know that when you're responsible
what's your money God looks down and God
sees that you're being and He blesses
you and we have yeah we're stewards of
what he gives us and we ought to be a
good Steward and then he just blesses
that you know then we're blessable yeah
you know and when you're not blessable
you know you know you make life worth
your way you know it it doesn't work you
go into debt amen amen well done well
done well certainly the uh the videos
you watched are all biblically based as
you know yeah and so uh yeah stuff like
get out of debt the borrowers leave the
lender there's a principal right there
you know which you guys did so
fabulously now we did see a video of you
on YouTube about like 30 like year years
ago where when when like you had hair so
you know yeah that one's been that one's
been going around I was yeah it's not
real here more of a little comb over
actually but uh it was the last vestiges
before it gave up the ghost yeah that's
uh I was like 30 something years old
yeah 32 years old or something yeah it's
crazy it is 30 years old that video yeah
wow when we first started doing this
stuff all right guys way to go hey we
got a cop we got the live and give box
for you baby steps millionaires book
that's your next stop and a Total Money
Makeover book as well as the Financial
Peace University membership live them or
give them all of that way to go very
proud of y'all congratulations thank you
all right Tim and Karen from Detroit
Michigan 80 000 paid off in five years
with their income get this going from 36
to 80. don't tell me it can't be done no
whining making 136 after this call jump
in count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one we're dead free
yeah
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
Jade Washington Ramsay personality is my
co-host today our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly is your one
place to find Reliable HVAC plumbing and
electrical providers near you Brands
like air serve Mr Rooter and Mr Electric
have local professionals ready to help
so stop wasting time scrolling through
the pages of results
visit neighborly.com today they're great
folks all right today's question comes
from Terry in Maryland my husband and I
have a HELOC with an adjustable rate it
started at 3.5 last year and now it's at
8.5 percent we owe 57 000 and our
current monthly payment is approximately
750 dollars we began paying an extra 500
toward it a month however this impacts
our lifestyle an ability to do the
things that we love such as travel
frequently as well as other Home
Improvements total owed with HELOC and
mortgage is about 429 000 are household
income is 275 000.
our only other debt is about payment
that we also make extra monthly payments
on
I'm trying to do my best here Dave is it
best to continue paying extra on the
current HELOC and hope the rates drop or
a find a loan with a lower fixed rate uh
fixed interest rate which may end up
being higher than the adjustable rate in
the future our goal is to pay this off
ASAP yet the eight percent makes this
difficult by the way my credit score is
800 plus
this is not be gentle this is not a long
time listener no this is not a long time
long time listeners don't close with
their credit score that's a good point
unless it's zero
Dave thank you Dave because you you gave
Grace and now I'm making fun of them all
the way through the whole email but
there you go I'm Gonna Give You Grace
okay
um you are a you are a first time
listener or a an early listener to us
um you've gotten yourself in a mess
the good news is you've got a great
great great great great income to get
yourself out of this mess
um I probably would not move the HELOC
for now
um I'd keep it right where it's at what
I would do if I were you
um is I would start working our plan
you've obviously found us you trust us
enough to write us a letter right so I'd
start working through this
um I live I I want to know more about
them Dave but I try to bust that income
down to living on about a hundred
thousand a year and I'd be taking the
majority of it 175 000 a year paying off
this debt and I'd probably be trying to
be debt free house in all one year
pay off the HELOC of fifty seven
thousand pay off the boat we don't know
how much the boat is but pay them both
off in one year for God's sakes you make
275 000 freaking dollars a year yeah
your mortgage could be gone in two and a
half years hey they might not be able to
listen I'm uh listen you you one of the
things I had to do
was
in order to get out in order to stop
being broke was I had to stop the
whining yeah that's so real I can so
whine to myself about how I work so hard
I'm entitled and my wife would look at
me and say yeah show this everyone
call the wambulance I love share
oh she's tough she's great she's mean
she's hateful and stuff like that no
she's crazy bust your bubble man
so I had to learn to talk to myself
Terry so I'm gonna talk to you that way
call the wambulance about your little
travel plans yeah you have a freaking
boat you didn't even pay for there's
your travel plan so go out on the boat
since you already have it that's your
travel plan that's it you can't do
anything else you're not allowed to
leave because you have to pay off your
debt in one year 57 000 plus the debt
minus 275 is still a lot of freaking
money no whining Allowed no whining it's
gonna go buy this stuff we're trying to
figure out a way to interest rate trick
yourself into spending more than you
make Congress has tried it for years and
it just doesn't work
let's talk about the credit score
okay
why not why not because I to close with
that oh and by the way my credit score
is 800 plus all that indicates to me all
that indicates mathematically is that
they possibly plan on using that credit
score more in the future oh if you're
touting that that lets me know okay this
matters to you you want it to be right
so that possibly in the future you can
use it again there's only one way to get
an 800 credit score only one way what's
that Dave borrow a lot of money
and pay a lot of interest when you pay
it all back on time
and that's the only way this this means
you have been playing make out with the
bank in the back seat of the car that's
what the credit score means okay it
means you've been playing kissy face
with the bank that's all it means it
does not mean you have a net worth it
does not mean you have an income it
doesn't mean you have nothing but you've
been kissing the bank all the time and
the bank is a butterface
you know what that is no
I can't talk about this on the video I'm
good just keep it there it means
everything looks good but their face oh
I got you I got you so now I understand
the bank is hiding the true yeah yeah
they all look good at closing time okay
um so there we go yeah oh my gosh oh my
gosh here we go
[Laughter]
the credit score is 100 derived by your
interaction with debt so bragging about
your credit score is like I love debt I
love debt I love debt that's why Jade is
saying she thinks you're going to go
back in dedicate here so if you want to
do the stuff we teach which is designed
to get you into wealth and peace as fast
as possible the shortest right way then
what you'd have to do is
uh get yourself out of debt and limit
your lifestyle to do that and so this is
about growing up it's about adulting
children do what feels good adults
devise a plan and follow it so don't be
playing kissy face with the bank anymore
you're not going to borrow your way out
of this you're going to pay your way out
of it thank God you have a fabulous
household income and you don't have a
lot of debt but you do have a lot of
symptoms of somebody who's getting ready
to make a huge mess that's right I mean
we just heard a debt-free scream making
36 000. they paid off 80 000 making
thirty six thousand yeah and it took
five years of sacrifice you've got maybe
12 months maybe yeah we don't know how
big the boat is you know yeah that's
still that's true we don't know how big
a boat is or at least here we go there
we go that's it
the um
that segment will go down in information
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Jessica is in
Georgia Jessica how can we help right
quick
hi yes thank you so much
even be like okay after that episode
what did you learn
um
yeah and I'm just excited that I
actually have something else I really
love your advice on um we've been really
just diligently praying and trying to
Steward our finances well
um we have uh 300 000 in cash in the
bank and we are trying to decide do we
invest this money into the market since
the market is low yeah basically it
should increase in the next couple years
or should we buy a house in cash now
you've been listening to the show since
you were a little bitty baby girl
I actually have some very early memories
you completely know the answer to this
question
I know like you completely know the
answer choices like do I buy a house in
cash you know the answer option you know
the answer any different what's the
answer Jessica
ding ding ding ding you get the prize
you know what happened is you got some
idiot friends that haven't got 300 000
but they do have an opinion
[Music]
don't take Financial advice from your
broke friends yes we have don't take
Financial advice from your broke friends
and don't take Financial advice from
Tick Tock unless it's one of our in one
of our accounts but other than that you
should yes good job advice yeah yeah
because it's all short-term thinking
it's all brought up by adolescents yeah
and so long-term thinking pay cash for
your house take what would have been a
house payment and go get rich with it oh
exciting very quickly she's young to
have a paid for house I don't know where
they got the 300 Grand I don't either
God that's incredible beautiful
beautiful well done well done hey call
Terry in Maryland and tell her how to do
this this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build well do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
Jay barshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five Helen is in Atlanta hi
Helen welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave hi
um everyone else
I'm calling um I forgot your name I'm
sorry that's all right
but I have I have a question that I'm
sure you're here a lot it's a student
loan question I know y'all like oh I'm
so sick of student loans
we know you're sick of them so we're
here to help you what's up
so I I'm kind of like in a very deep
hole I'm at the point where I'm very
hopeless at this point I'm trying to
figure out how can I handle my student
loan debt which is now at three hundred
and eleven thousand dollars which keeps
um growing as each day goes by my
interest rate on that student loan which
is 311 000 is um some of them are seven
percent some are 6.80 and some are 7.60
are they private all of them are they
private or public they're not private
they're they're public all of them with
the Department of Education okay
um what's your degree in I am
so I have
threes I have one in um Information
Technology one in um Conflict Management
which that was a waste of money
um and um I had a law degree hmm
okay and so what do you make
um so right now I'm only making 85k
doing what
um right now I'm doing compliance
okay
why
um uh because well I was um a staff
attorney
um but I wasn't making a lot of money as
a staff attorney because I worked for a
non-profit
um I wanted to switch over
um to do more corporate
um type of legal work
um and that's when I switched over last
year
um to to this to try to try something
else
um and which I did get a paid bump in
making this transfer I am married I have
a child uh what is your husband
he only makes 50. okay how old is your
information technology degree
hours years old um you're not up to
Snuff on what's going on right now then
not at all not at all so your best path
to an income is through your law degree
exactly okay
can I ask about the your spouse he makes
50K
you're not combining your income
um no we are not because well
why not we're not really combining our
income because he says my student loan
is my suitable so he's not contributing
to that does he have debt
um he he owes about he has a
there was a garnishment or whatever it's
not garnish you but
um he has a debt about 30 well more than
that he has a 30 000
um that plus he has a car loan I do not
have a car loan the only debt I have is
the house so the house is in your name
we we got troubles girlfriend
we have a lot of troubles in the house
basically if you add the house and you
add the student loan that I'm at half a
million dollars in debt at this point
yeah that's
um so number one chance you've the only
chance you've got to cleaning up his
mess and cleaning up your message for
you guys to join forces and quit acting
like your roommates fighting over whose
mayonnaise is in the dead gum
refrigerator
besides that boy child is no money
genius we've proven that already
so it's not like he's sitting over here
on some high horse
he's already behind he's further in debt
ratio to his income than you are and his
income potential so anyway number one uh
we need an attitude adjustment in our
marriage and learn to get on the same
page and work towards things together
um and then number two we're gonna have
to do something with your law degree
that makes you as much money as possible
and it's not what you're doing now
I mean a law degree you ought to be
north of six figures what was coming out
of the gate what was the intent when you
got that degree what was the intention
it's collecting degrees like a
thermometer
um my intent was always wanted to be an
attorney
um but but in the except for the part
when you did Conflict Management on the
part when you did it um yeah Information
Systems yeah I mean what's the next step
taking the bar you got the bar sure I've
already taken tomorrow yeah staff
attorney so then what I I need to
understand what's stopping you from
making double what you're yeah
because the industry is not paying well
I'm not gonna I don't want to litigate
um that's one thing I do not want to
wear the game why
um so I have to because I I've done it
for three years and I hinted it okay you
did it for 30 years
I did it for three years oh three three
years okay
and I hated it and I was like in
depression the only the only option that
I saw out of this situation is to work
for a nonprofit which you know that's
not gonna make that much money at all it
doesn't work you need to make some money
in 10 years yeah you guys both need to
make as much money as you can possibly
make because you have a deep deep hole
and a medium-sized to small shovel and
we need to get the size of your shovel
up your income up and some of the jobs
that you do here here you can make a
hundred thousand dollars more a year you
can be out of this debt in three years
yeah even if you didn't like what you
were doing like litigation for three
whole years if you made if you made 185
we'll go do it for three years and shut
up exactly because it's less depressing
dealing with litigation than it is
dealing with 311 000 in student loan
debt
and that's the mic drop
that's that's all yeah I'm still here
yeah I'm still here I'm not sure it's
litigation I don't care but you're
hiding in these stupid but half paying
corporate jobs while you need to go at
the tip of the spear and go make some
dead gum money for the good of your life
because you're looking at a mountain
don't know how I'm gonna climb it and
you're standing there with a law degree
in your hand
so you it's an income issue you can make
it out at 85 but it's going to take you
three or four times longer you can make
it out without your husband's
participation but it's going to take you
three or four times longer and oh by the
way when you do finally get out dumb
butt's gonna still be in debt over there
yeah what we're telling you the the you
part of it is just such a small part of
this equation because if you're getting
up your income think about think about
this if you double your income he
doubles his income you guys attack this
thing together you're moving quickly and
you're on the same page
you'd be wealthy or end up wealthy at
the end of the story
he can't double his income because he
doesn't have any of the education behind
us as well as he's not motivated
second part not the first part the
problem is he's not motivated because I
don't care if he doubles his income in
his field I just want him to go out
working and bringing in more income I
don't care if he's delivering pizzas I
want him to get after this because you
guys together decide that this is what
you need to do it's emotionally
debilitating to be doing it by yourself
when you're married
so it's very hard but you guys it is an
income to debt ratio problem
mathematically get your income up so
that you can attack this faster and
faster and faster and faster and look at
it as a temporary thing it doesn't have
to be a career choice it's a temporary
thing you need to do something and go
make an extra 100K a year this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five she shall forever
be known as everyone else
and everyone else it's like a band it's
like my co-host everyone else
that's good we got a lot of input that
way that's right lots of input Lots
in Orlando hey Joshua welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave well a lot of big life changes
have happened to me recently uh last
December I graduated with my aerospace
engineering degree wow I recently got
and entry level engineering position at
Nasa uh making 70 000 a year he is a
rocket scientist okay
so just got married last week and my
wife uh makes 40 000 a year and we are
about to finish baby step two
um we've been doing it for about four
months and crazy enough we have paid off
forty thousand dollars in debt by
selling my fancy truck and everything
else way to go
um my question is my wife and I have
always had this dream of owning like 15
20 acres of land uh having cattle goat
chickens having a bunch of kids
um and if you were in my shoes
how would you go about doing this we
would love to build a house but we know
in the past you said that's not really
optimal
um for first-time home buyers we were
even thinking about just buying the land
you know putting RV on the land for a
year or two and then slowly building a
house just what are your thoughts and
all this and how would you go about
doing this
okay
um so you got married when
last week
so we always have wanted you out for a
week
um please tell me you're not on your
honeymoon right now okay
Congratulations by the way a lot of
wonderful things so you're what 23-24
uh 27 I was in uh school for eight years
um change major once and then I had to
drop out dude how old is she
she is 26. okay all right
um
we have done a lot of sacrificial things
in our lives I've been married 41 years
to hit our goals uh never once was one
of them my wife considered that she
would live in an RV for one of my goals
that never that was never one of the
possibilities
um like not a freaking chance okay I'm
just saying so we rent an apartment
first or something I don't know so uh I
could be wrong but that might you guys
really want a piece of land and I think
that's wonderful I like dirt too I've
got some dirt myself and
um uh but uh
yeah the living in the RV thing and
unless she's uh an unusual lady that's
probably not her dream that might be
your well it's actually her idea believe
it or not and I'm all for it but uh an
unusual well I just yeah I don't believe
but okay I mean I didn't believe it till
you said it so I believe I believe what
you say but all right um it's uh
what would I do I don't know what you'll
do because you're willing to do things
I'm not willing to do and my wife is not
willing to do namely living in an RV
okay and so uh at any stage of our life
no matter how sacrificial we've been or
how broke we've been that never was on
the list
so uh uh I mean we've lived in some
dumpy one bedroom apartments to get
there but never did do that not saying
one's better than the other I'm just
saying not something that Sharon's going
to say anyway all that to say we would
buy a nice
starter home that is very generic
because generic homes Is Not Unusual in
other words they go up in value more
likely than weird homes and then we
would get that thing and we pay it down
as fast as we could pay it down
somewhere along in there we'd save up
some money and pay cash for the land
we'd sell the house and we'd rent while
we built on the land and that would be
the two-step procedure that we would do
and it's we did that but we did it over
a number of years I wouldn't think it's
going to take you guys that long but I
mean your first place
it just feels uh like bad relational
advice for me to tell you as Dave Ramsey
that your first home after you've been
married a week should be an RV well
there's there's a fairy tale
element to this it's like we just got
married this is our Dream to have this
land in this house with lots of kids and
um I would live under a bridge for you
yeah until I'm under the bridge well
there's I want them to have all that but
I I agree with you Dave because because
at least if you go somewhere you get a
small starter house first or you know
whatever that is at least has the
ability to appreciate some value over
time while you're saving we know that RV
is not going to do that that's a good
point you know so there's that piece of
it and then
either way there's going to be some time
that you're going to wait here because
you've got to buy the land so you may as
well wait
in a house at home yeah yeah so I I
would just buy something very boring
Kinda Yeah I mean that's your first home
and concentrate on uh your first year of
marriage so there's a scripture in the
Old Testament that talks about in first
Samuel that the Warriors in the in
Israel in the time of Samuel uh were not
allowed to go to war their first year of
marriage they were required to invest in
their marriage for the first year so um
and at times I built several homes with
my wife over the years and at times it's
it's some similar to War
I see
I know I get it no I mean the last the
last couple have been pretty good yeah
uh the first one we about killed each
other but the uh um yeah and The
Decorator almost had The Decorator
assessment but I found out that was
illegal so um you can't do that Dave but
the um
yeah so that's you it's
really getting to know each other and
spending your energy on
the project of relationship building
instead of the project of Home Building
that's so true that's that's just good
uh first year of marriage try to try to
take on as few complicated and large
projects as possible I agree in the
first year
um there's enough to deal with just your
mother-in-law I mean there's just that
and so you are correct or her
mother-in-law or I don't know your
mother I don't I mean whatever you know
I don't know it's something it could be
a mother it could be a father you could
have an overbearing controlling father
like my kids and so
you know that that could happen but yeah
I mean you got to learn to deal with it
and I you can do all of that Joshua but
you're uh you're you're a very
precise-minded individual and
um
I suspect uh the project of building a
home will be very precise for you
oh yeah and uh so I really want you to
precisely and I if you're a mushon I
would tell you to not do anything for
you yeah just like you heard me say
before and if you did do something it
would be a boring little starter house
and then let's make the building on the
land the step two the second home second
home and it's gonna it's still gonna be
fun yeah the whole process is going to
be fun you've got time you guys are yeah
it's going to be fun and you know
word of the wise goats aren't as fun as
they sound like they are open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and you're running now I will get
hate mail from the goat people but um
there we go they hadn't offended as many
people today so I thought it should add
to the list all right that's the process
so it's a good thing
like I talked to a couple uh I remember
gosh many years ago on the show and it
was the first time I ran into this they
were worth about two million dollars and
they did what he's talking about I was
kind of in all of them and that what
they did they bought a a five thousand
dollar single wide extremely used
trailer
and stuck it on a piece of land and
lived there until they saved up three
hundred thousand dollars cash and then
they built a cash house and and fast
forward we're sitting with them they're
not even 30 and they're worth over a
million dollars with paid for 300 000
house on a nice track of land and we're
down in the Alabama area at the time and
that was the first time I heard somebody
going that extreme and they're like
you're gonna love this and I'm like yeah
I love that you did it yeah and uh but
I'm no Sharon was not gonna do that that
was not on her list and I don't it's not
wrong there is a level of sacrifice that
you're going to endure the depth of it
will the deeper the faster you're
propelled but the depth of it is your
choice yeah yeah that's good and the
fact that they did a five thousand
dollar
RV there was a single wide yeah worse
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage George
and Carol are with us hey guys how are
you funny you Dave you're doing great
better than we deserve same here same
here welcome where do you live San
Antonio Texas all right fun how much
data have you paid off paid off six
hundred and twenty thousand dollars
how long did that take it took us 39
months 30. I'm gonna do this a lot
that's a lot and your range of income
during that uh three years and three
months uh we started out at uh 313
000 and ended at 348 000. goodness
gracious what do you all do for a living
ah I'm a retired Soldier 30 years Army
retired medically retired and uh 25
years retired Air Force wow and that's
the this is all retirement income
no and also well I retired in 2010 and
they picked me up as doing the same
thing I really I get individuals
deployed ah that is my job Civil Service
oh okay I see all right so all of that
combined wow yes sir well thank you for
your service both of your career then
wow and San Antonio definitely that
makes sense okay very cool whoa so 620
000 uh that's your house thank you yes
sir oh look at that weird people
you are debt free baby yeah I love it
what's this house worth
a million dollars now wow come on
somebody
I love it and you got this fabulous
military retirement thank you thank you
thank you for your service over and over
and over again and uh you got other Nest
Egg Bill yes sir how much so we have
over seven hundred thousand dollars in
retirement we have um so you're worth
around two million dollars now yes sir
wow wow wow because of you because of
you any of it
you have to tighten the shot group man
that's something yeah put those rounds
down range in the right direction I like
it I have to be transparent with you
Dave because at first I did not want to
do it I was totally yeah but she might
tighten the shot group so you need to be
careful
this is not a lady you want to mess with
I can tell
so how did she get you into it other
than threatening you with a shot group
well believe it or not uh I have to give
it to uh two couples uh a jazz and Chris
Brown and Leonard and Pam Turner
Jazz and Chris Brown they came to our
house and taught us FPU for nine weeks
wow one-on-one because I was totally
against it whoa and force-fed you yes
and once we got a board I was Hook Line
and Sinker okay so how many weeks into
you being force-fed did it turn into you
were the you were a gang on game on I
say on the third week okay when I had to
cut those credit cards okay all right
all right I mean what kind of friend
does that that's a friend that sure is
we were in the same life group we had a
IRS debt we were married eight years ago
today's our anniversary
when we were married we didn't join our
income so we were just living paycheck
to paycheck when the bills came in we
paid them he paid his bills I paid my
bills but 39 months ago we had well it
was four years ago we had an IRS debt
over 11
and so I said Hey Baby Slow Down on the
spending because we owed IRS eleven
thousand dollars
and about a week after that I was at
home in a palette of mulch was dropped
off at the house and I called him up and
asked him how much it was he paid over
700 for this Mulch and we still owe the
IRS and I lost my mind
that and that was my I've had it yes it
was and here comes the force feeding
yeah
at the time I was volunteering at the
homeless shelter and every story was the
same with the women my husband died or
her husband used up the entire nest egg
and you look up and now she's homeless
and that wasn't going to be me I said in
my family I started with my grandmother
she died with that I said my mother
who's a widow who's in dire need of
money without an airstake I did not want
that to be me you saw of it that it's
like I saw all of that in the mulch
so to speak yeah whoa that yeah that
pile of manure will get your attention
it sure will oh that's fun now I
remember you guys I met you guys on a
coordinator rally right yes so how did
that transformation happen to where
someone's Force feeding you FPU now
you're doing it and now you're doing it
um we had a again Chris and Brad uh
Jasmine Brown they were teaching the
course in our church so my wife was like
hey we want to do that as well so we
joined them we um did a coal host guest
with them and after that we're like hey
we need to do one of our own I love it
wow what church you go to now word
Covenant Church in San Antonio Texas
well thanks for teaching it we
appreciate it very very much our church
is also debt-free in this I love it I
love it you guys are a force to be
reckoned with uh what do you tell people
now that you're coordinating you pay off
620 000 in three years and some change
oh my gosh house and everything worth
two million dollars retired military
you're living the American dream tell
them how to become debt free what'd you
do for that three years we joined forces
we got on a budget
and we tightened up our shot group
everything else was secondary today we
stayed gazelle intensity through the
whole thing we did not give up and uh so
what we do now is if I see someone like
say a plumber or electrician come to the
house and say hey uh how's your finances
they'll talk to us a little bit then
I'll go and I'll grab one of your books
and I'll pass it to them say hey
um you might want to read this that's
wow so we're trying to give it back yeah
something the Lord didn't give us all
these resources to expend it all that's
right because we get our glory to God
because if it wasn't for him we would
not be standing here at this time no
that's true that's true for sure well
done you guys you're amazing Your Heroes
in so many ways beautifully beautifully
done how's it feel to have no payments
in the world
outstanding free peace
we're not in flight or fight mode
anymore yes yeah no homeless shelter
because of uh a pallet of the the BS
we're in a position to help others the
widows the orphans the single parents to
the homeless clothes feed we're allowed
to focus on our Ministries amen amen you
guys are beautiful you're fabulous I
love it I love it I love it well we've
got the live and give box for you it
sounds like you've got good use for it
the baby steps millionaires book which
you're living proof that that happens
you are baby steps Millionaires and The
Total Money Makeover book as well and
then another Financial Peace University
membership you'll find a good use for
that I'm sure for someone coming into
one of your classes that that maybe that
helps them get started so very well done
you guys are amazing George and Carol
San Antonio Texas wow 620 000 paid off
house and everything Landing them in a 2
million dollar net worth making 30 did
that in 39 months making 313 to 348
military retirement plus continuing to
work count it down let's hear a debt
free screen
free two one
[Applause]
oh
love it wow
I love it
goals yeah hashtag goals all the years
of doing this I have never heard tight
in the shot group in reference to that
I've heard it when I'm on the shooting
range but I've never heard it in
reference to that looks Carol is not
messing around
she does not miss I wouldn't want to be
downrange
what a great Target what a great job
Heroes man very cool
you know you're out there right now and
you're 19 or you're 20 years old uh
you're starting your military career did
you listen to that young man real woman
did you listen to that unbelievable
that's where those people are and they
did that serving their country so
beautiful beautiful beautiful very well
done wow ding ding ding ding ding this
is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day Ecclesiastes 10
10 if the ax is dull and its Edge
unsharpened more strength is needed but
skill will bring success
Henry Ford said most people spend more
time and energy going around the
problems than trying to solve them Dr
Stephen Covey in his book Seven Habits
used to talk about are the
tree beater
that if you sit you know uh one
Lumberjack goes in with an ax and he's
knocking down I don't know make it up 20
trees a day and the next day 23s a day
the next day 23s a day the other guy
comes in he's doing 20 25 trees a day
then he's doing 15 trees a day then 10
trees a day finally goes over the guy
who's const consistently doing it he
said what are you doing he said well
every morning I have to sharpen my ax
and you keep a sharp ax the trees go
down yeah and you keep sharp if the ax
is dull and it's Edge unsharpened more
strength is needed but skill will bring
success Ecclesiastes says there you go
good word must have been where he got
that open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Annie is with
us in San Francisco hi Annie how are you
hi I'm great it's so nice to talk to you
you too what's up
um all of a sudden I got very nervous so
it's okay we've never lost a patient how
can we help good good to hear it well
I'm trying to figure out if we should
keep our earthquake insurance and I
would love your advice yes I live in San
Francisco
okay well we are so we are not in San
Francisco we are in a suburb of San
Francisco
specifically okay I mean you're in an
earthquake zone
we are but it's what I cannot figure out
is why we are we seem to be the only
Chumps in our 1.8 million dollar house
because all the houses here are insanely
priced
we seem to be the only ones who have
kept our earthquake insurance I have
talked to so many of my neighbors and
our friends in this town nobody else
seems to have purchased it or kept it
once our our premiums went way up well
if they went high enough I don't know
what they are I guess I should have
asked that
um I don't know what the how high they
are but I mean there are people that buy
earthquake insurance in Tennessee that's
humorous yeah because there's not been
an earthquake in Tennessee because it's
probably but it's probably super cheap
ours for the longest time ours was about
2 000 a year and in the last couple of
years our premiums gone up to 6 000 a
year so it's more expensive than our
home I mean by far so what would I mean
again all insurance is probabilities
it's all statistics
that establishes price okay right and so
what they're trying to determine like
for instance it's it's very difficult to
get homeowners insurance of any kind in
Florida now
because of hurricanes right because that
the insurance companies have abandoned
the state because of that
um one of the problems you guys are
facing in California is a lot of the
insurance companies have abandoned the
state because your state government are
idiots
and the regulations are crazy and so
they've driven businesses out that that
they don't want they don't want to write
in California because it's just too
difficult with the regulations so I that
may be what's driving this up it could
be but it could be just statistics that
okay if we're more if we're an insurance
company we're going to cover a thousand
million dollar houses million 800 000
houses would you say yours was then um
and on average out of a thousand of them
how much are going to have earthquake
damage in a 10-year period of time
you know then okay that's 60 000 bucks
and so that you know they're running the
statistics down uh or 600 000 bucks they
run the stats down on actually that they
actually make money on all insurance if
they do their statistics right all
Insurance makes money but some of it's
work not worth some of it's not worth
the risk on our part so we take it right
but so what's your household income
our household income it depends on the
year but it's between 350 and 450 000.
okay and so if if the house
uh I mean what you got to think about is
just the probability uh what is the
chances of a total Destruction of this
house while you live there I mean there
have been severe earthquakes in the last
100 years in San Francisco right 200
years for sure absolutely right and
it'll help
I I
sure don't
for earthquake in California
we all have to get it if we want it
through the California earthquake
Authority which is like a public you
know it's like a private and that's the
six thousand dollars
yeah exactly so like our State Farm Home
Insurance
yeah exactly exactly yeah because they
couldn't figure out they couldn't figure
out the probabilities on it I I have a I
have a question in my mind and I could
be totally wrong in my mind I'm thinking
okay 1.8 million dollars this is gonna
cost me
500 bucks a month
I feel like I would just do it for the
probability of living where there's such
a pro some some sort of damage even if
it's not catastrophic right with your
income and I know the ratios are
different in San Francisco but I'm
thinking with your income how big of a
piece how big a piece of 500 of your
world is 500 a month it's not because I
make
because all of these other people who
have income you know either around ours
or north of ours you know they don't
seem to have it but if there's an
earthquake they're going to be the chump
yeah I mean but it's a matter it's just
a matter of probabilities what do you
change I mean in in the how long are you
going to live in this house you know I'm
gonna live there 10 years what's the
chances of a total loss in that 10-year
period of time no one knows obviously
but that's how you would decide if
you're a trump and so it doesn't make
you a chump it's uh to buy it or for
that matter not to buy it they have
chosen
the other people to become self-insured
they're taking the risk themselves
obviously you're already aware of that
and so like I've got a friend that has a
house
um on the beach in Mexico okay they the
area that he's in has small uh tropical
storms and occasional small hurricanes
the house is almost totally concrete
because it's built for that area and so
if a hurricane comes through there it's
going to like blast its furniture blast
the windows out but the rest of the
house will be just fine and he probably
hurricane insurance down there and it
was ridiculous I mean it was like 25 000
a year and he's like nah I'll just
self-insure it
and he's got plenty of money he can if
the whole stinking thing blows down he
can build it back yeah right but he's
just like I'm I'm just gonna you know
I'm gonna put hurricane shutters on it
I'm gonna take care of the house and you
know he was describing It All To Me it
made sense it made sense that he's
taking the risk but he can take the risk
so if you if the house fell down do you
have a mortgage on it
we have about 375
000 left on it what's your net worth I
was just about to ask
um depending on which way the wind blows
we're between 5.3 and 5.7 so this is not
it doesn't ruin your life
this is just a peace argument is it
giving you peace or is it not giving you
peace it will having it make you sleep
better at night well not having it make
it make you sleep better at night
oh that's a good question Jade it gives
me peace okay and you're not a challenge
it also makes me feel like I'm a trump
the only one I will mathematically tell
you you're not a chump you freaking live
in San Francisco earthquakes occur okay
you're not a chump you're not you're not
getting messed over if you told me 60
000 a year I'd be going there getting
messed over but six thousand no you're
not uh it did go way up but the reason
way up is the more the uh insurance
companies got hammered by California
claims on earthquake that's why they
quit writing it and then the only way to
get it is get it through a socialized
thing with the state a public private
right socialism and so yeah that's the
only way you can get it and that's part
of what that's the only way you can get
dead gum insurance in Florida right now
just about there's just a few companies
riding it very difficult and so
um uh it's the exact same thing it's the
probability the event becomes hard to
predict so the insurance companies
aren't going to cover it yeah so I don't
I mean I know a lot about Actuarial
tables and I don't think you're a chump
but I don't think you'd be a chump if
you're self-insured it either it's not a
you're not you're not measurably dumb
either way this is no fun writing a 500
check every month to something that is
very fluid that puts this hour of the
Ramsey showing the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]